hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
we have some interesting news to talk
about today as usual i know we had a lot
of stuff going on yesterday with the
warmonger and the tyrants test and i'll
explain everything about that it's not
exactly about the character but just
let me explain when we get to that part
of the video but it's always like to be
if you do enjoy subscribe if you're new
and let's get started with today's video
so first off
right off the start the new character
that we saw in the tyrants test
warmonger is confirmed to be the new
hero
in this season on august 6th and they
also have a road map for us
so from july 22nd to august 6th is going
to be the tyrant's test where we get to
fight against
the new character and then on august 6th
comes the hero
and then a little bit later is going to
be the event pass from the rise of
warmongers event
this event is going to be covered a lot
more next week though so we don't have
too much info on it today
but to kind of explain today what's
going to be happening today's video is
going to be covering mostly the core
combat update that's also going to be
launching on august 6th the day that the
hero comes out
with the event and the new hero being
talked a lot more in depth
next week so nothing on the character
just yet but like i said next week it'll
be a hell of info on that character i'm
super excited to see what the warmonger
is about
but a little bit of story was actually
shown about the character so pretty much
these warmongers are like a group of
dark heroes some from the old blackstone
legion
some just real [ __ ] and they have
this new kind of power called corruption
which is that poison stuff we talked
about yesterday
which they get from these green stones
called draconite and the plan for the
new hero is to also change a few maps
during the event
like how we're seeing with the current
map right now from test your metal
of course they're going to be taking
maybe a couple other maps and then
kind of sprinkling some of that poison
or corruption to kind of show their
influence on the map
and that's going to be really sick to
see so to start is the combat update
and the whole point of the combat update
is to improve the consistency of attacks
enhance offense and counter light spam
as effective as possible
basically what that means is that for
consistency this has to do with delayed
and buffered attacks and making them not
separate you can see this a lot better
in the visual example they're providing
but of course as we've explained before
buffered attacks is that if you were to
spam the led attack button as fast as
possible
those moves are coming out as as early
as they possibly can
that is considered buffered but if you
take your time just slightly
and maybe like two or three hundred
milliseconds later that's more of a
delayed attack they're not coming out
exactly at the very possible second that
they can
just a slight bit later i've been very
consistent at landing these sort of
attacks with jj's heavies but it's a
little bit hard to land with some of the
other characters in the game but they're
going to be trying to get rid of this of
course as this is just a pain especially
for new players and it's a little hard
to determine you know whether something
is delayed or buffered and to react
accordingly to that
it just takes way too much time and by
that time you've already been hit
the other changes include stamina as
well now i want you to pay attention to
the stamina bars when you're parried
because normally when you're parried you
lose a lot of stamina for being parried
but now in the update you will lose zero
only the stamina from the move you threw
and if they happen to block it is being
taken away as they stated parrying
allows the player to start a combo and
that person who threw the attack takes
damage because they've been parried
which is enough of a negative as is
taking away the stamina is just overkill
at that point
next up is light spam to compare the two
combat update arimusha on the very right
side
of the screen through 10 light attacks
and he was out of stamina
but on live he threw the exact same
amount of lights and he has like 70
percent of his stamina left
that is the biggest intention for
situations like these and that's the
easiest way i can explain how light spam
is going to be changed a bit
for a basic summary of what we just
talked about i know moves are going to
get faster which is a huge problem with
a lot of the console players obviously
because
moves are already fast enough as is but
with the introduction of faster moves
but also
no stamina loss on parries lights taking
more stamina to use and
most of the moves if not all the moves
doing less damage
it's gonna even this out and make fights
a lot longer like they were intended to
so i think this is a fantastic change
and then to end it they had some more
specific changes
dodge attacks have been slightly
lengthened to counter light spam
and then orochi light chains are slower
and he has a top heavy unblockable
and highlander opening and chained
lights in defensive stance
are faster i know i just totally blew
through that but orochi having a
unblockable at all is just insane i
think it's been four years since i mean
it's been
he's been here since the very beginning
and he hasn't gotten an unblockable so
that's
huge news for roche players they could
finally have unblockables
that's pretty [ __ ] cool yeah with
that that's pretty much the end of
today's video like i said we're gonna be
getting a lot more information on what
this new event is what the new character
is about all the
juicy information that we've been
waiting for ever since yesterday so no
worries just tune in next week and i'll
get you guys covered with all of that
information
as always like the v if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new and take care
guys
see you next week goodbye
[Music]
you